This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Your world has not been designed for you. In large part, it has been designed for the average person. Throughout your education, you've been given standardized tests and been graded by how well you perform compared to the average. Building codes, turns, rates, the Dow Jones, all these measurements are based around the concept of an average. And it's okay, we know you're not average. You're really special. Ah, thanks, Avery Trouffman. Well, I mean it, you're not average. No one is, not completely.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。你的世界并非为你设计。在很大程度上，它是为普通人设计的。在你的整个教育过程中，你做过标准化考试，并根据你与平均水平相比的表现来打分。建筑规范、转弯半径、道琼斯指数，所有这些测量都是围绕平均值的概念展开的。没关系，我们知道你并不普通。你真的很特别。啊，谢谢你，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。我是说真的，你并不普通。没有人是普通的，至少不完全是。
But the concept of average affects us all. Everything seems to be based around this reference point of average. And obviously, everything about society is built this way, but I'd never really thought of it until I dug into this new science that I'm a part of. This is Todd Rose. My name is Todd Rose. I am the director of the My & Brain Education program at the Harvard Graduate School of Education. He's also the author of the book The End of Average. But to get to that, first we have to start with the beginning of average, because it wasn't always a thing. The concept of average, because it wasn't always a thing.
但平均值的概念影响着我们所有人。一切似乎都以这个平均值的参考点为基础。显而易见，整个社会就是这样构建的，但我从未真正思考过这一点，直到我深入研究了我所参与的这项新科学。这是托德·罗斯。我叫托德·罗斯。我是哈佛大学教育研究生院“心智、大脑与教育”项目的主任。他也是《平均的终结》一书的作者。但要讲到这一点，首先我们得从平均值的起源讲起，因为它并非一直存在。平均值的概念，因为它并非一直存在。
The concept of average, as we know it, was pioneered by a Belgian mathematician and astronomer named Adolf Ketalai. So Ketalai is the person who actually coins the term the average man, and he is in like the 1830s, he is actually an astronomer in Belgium. Today the way that most people get a handle on any set of numbers is to calculate the average. But in Ketalais time, astronomers were some of the only people who did this. Basically, averages were a way to compensate for the imprecise tools that astronomers were working with in 1830. If you were trying to time the movement of Saturn, you would etch little scratches on your glass of your telescope,
我们所知道的平均值概念，是由一位名叫阿道夫·凯特莱的比利时数学家兼天文学家开创的。所以凯特莱实际上是创造了“平均人”这个术语的人，大约在1830年代，他实际上是比利时的一位天文学家。今天，大多数人掌握任何一组数字的方法都是计算平均值。但在凯特莱的时代，天文学家是仅有的几类这样做的人之一。基本上，平均值是用来弥补1830年代天文学家所使用的不精确工具的方法。如果你试图计时土星的运动，你会在望远镜的玻璃上刻下小划痕，
and as soon as it crossed one, you'd start counting, and you'd stop counting after it crossed the other, and then you'd write it down. But you can imagine, like, even if you're off by half a second, it's gonna introduce a lot of error. And so, they realized if they wanted to make sense of taming the heavens, they needed more precision in their estimates.
一旦它穿过其中一个，你就开始计时，穿过另一个后你停下来，然后把它写下来。但你可以想象，即使你偏差了半秒钟，也会引入大量的误差。因此，他们意识到，如果他们想理解驾驭星空，他们的估算就需要更高的精度。
And they realized that if you had, say, 10 measurements, and they were all slightly different, if you added them together and divided them by 10, you'd get a better approximation of the true measurement. If you just average together our measurements, you're way more likely to be closer to the truth, right? And you end up getting kind of a bell curve of measurement errors. Kevley was the first to take this tool of astronomers and apply it to people.
他们意识到，如果你有比方说10个测量值，而且它们都略有不同，如果你把它们加起来再除以10，你就会得到对真实测量值更好的近似。如果你把我们的测量值平均在一起，你更有可能接近真相，对吧？最后你会得到一种测量误差的正态分布曲线。凯特莱是第一个将天文学家的这个工具应用到人身上的人。
In the early 1840s, KELOLAY finds a data set of the chest measurements of 5,738 Scottish soldiers. KELOLAY added together each of the measurements and divided it by the total sum of the soldiers, and that result, 39 and 3 1,quarters inches, was one of the very first times a scientist had calculated the average size of a human feature. But he brings with it the idea of truth, that the average chest size is true, and that all the individuals are like error, that nature is striving for the average soldier. This means the average measurement is the true measurement,
在1840年代初，凯特莱找到了一组包含5738名苏格兰士兵胸围的数据集。凯特莱将每个测量值加起来，除以士兵的总数，得出的结果是39又四分之三英寸，这是科学家第一次计算出人类特征的平均尺寸。但他随之带来了真理的概念，即平均胸围是真实的，而所有个体都像是误差，自然界正在努力争取平均士兵。这意味着平均测量值就是真实测量值，
the platonic ideal, the perfect Scottish soldier, as a chest that is 39 and 3 ¼ inches, according to Ketale. So he's the one that decides not only his average mathematically useful, it's morally the way to think about people. And so he basically finds averages anywhere he can possibly find them.
柏拉图式的理想状态，完美的苏格兰士兵，根据凯特莱的说法，他的胸围是39又四分之三英寸。因此，不仅是数学上的平均值有用，他还是决定从道德角度来看待人类的人。于是他基本上在任何可能找到的地方寻找平均值。
And he just has like a field day. He measures all kinds of other people and averages them. He creates something called the Ketalai Index for measuring ratios of average height and average weight. And actually, we still use it today. Just now it's called the Body Mass Index or BMI. Ketalai would say, if you talked about height, everyone, if they were optimally fed,
他简直如鱼得水。他测量了各种其他人群并对其进行平均。他创造了一种叫做“凯特莱指数”的东西，用于测量平均身高和平均体重的比例。实际上，我们今天仍在使用它。只是现在它被称为身体质量指数，即BMI。凯特莱会说，如果你谈论身高，每个人，如果他们得到了最佳营养，
if they were under the same environmental conditions, would have been average. So his view was that what you're striving for is the continual improvement of the average of the group. And it wasn't all just physical. Kedaleg combs through various data sets for marriages, murders, and suicides, and calculates the averages for them. He figures out there's such a thing as a normal suicide rate, which is really, really bizarre at the time, almost scandalous. Nowadays, when we're so used to the stability of big, massive amounts of data, that it's hard to put yourself in their shoes, but like back then, they really thought that something like, say, suicide
如果他们在相同的环境条件下，都会是平均身高。所以他的观点是，你所追求的是群体平均水平的持续改善。而且这不仅仅局限于生理方面。凯特莱梳理了关于婚姻、谋杀和自杀的各种数据集，并计算了它们的平均值。他发现存在所谓的正常自杀率，这在当时非常非常离奇，甚至近乎丑闻。如今，当我们习惯了海量数据的稳定性时，很难设身处地为他们着想，但在当时，他们真的认为诸如自杀之类的事情
was such a personal decision that there couldn't possibly be any pattern there. But suddenly there were patterns of body size, of intelligence, of birth, of death. People became statistics. Their behavior starts to become predictable. Suddenly, human life went by the numbers. So obviously, the first interpretation is, well, wait a minute, maybe there's no free will, right?
是如此私人的决定，以至于不可能存在任何规律。但突然间，身体大小、智力、出生、死亡都有了规律。人们变成了统计数字。他们的行为开始变得可以预测。突然之间，人类的生活完全按数字运转。显然，第一种解释是，等一下，也许没有自由意志，对吧？
Maybe there's laws of society just like there's laws of physics. And so that kick started a whole bunch of people like Karl Marx, who loved Ketale. And Ketale becomes a huge star. In his time, Ketale was up there with the likes of Sir Isaac Newton. His science of averages was this remarkable cutting edgeway to assess the health, wellness, and progress of populations. He's really active in the 1820s, 1830s, 1840s, all the way into the 50s and 60s.
也许社会规律就像物理规律一样。这就引发了一大批人，比如卡尔·马克思，他非常喜欢凯特莱。凯特莱成了一个大明星。在那个时代，凯特莱的地位堪比艾萨克·牛顿爵士。他的平均值科学是评估人口健康、福祉和进步的一种卓越的前沿方法。他在1820年代、1830年代、1840年代都非常活跃，一直持续到50年代和60年代。
And the 1860s brings us to the US Civil War and to another super fan of Ketale's science of averages, Abraham Lincoln. When the Civil War is going in the North, Lincoln actually decides they're kind of getting their butt kicked, frankly. In large part because this war had gotten so huge and unwieldy, Lincoln doesn't really have a handle on the Northern Army. And he's like, look, we don't even know who our soldiers are.
1860年代迎来了美国内战，也迎来了凯特莱平均值科学的另一个超级粉丝——亚伯拉罕·林肯。内战在北方进行时，坦白说，林肯其实认为他们被打得屁滚尿流。很大程度上是因为这场战争变得如此庞大和难以控制，林肯对北方军队根本无法掌控。他说，听着，我们甚至不知道我们的士兵是谁。
We don't know how well fed they are. We don't know what kind of armor they need. We don't know how well fed they are. We don't know what kind of armor they need. We don't know anything about them. Lincoln decided that the Union Army needed more information about its soldiers in order to best distribute resources. So he ordered this enormous study to assess the Union Army physically, medically, and mentally. And then in explicit obedience to Ketalais' new science, averages were calculated and reported. They actually say, basically, we're following the father of this new field,
我们不知道他们是否吃饱穿暖。我们不知道他们需要什么样的装甲。我们不知道他们是否吃饱穿暖。我们不知道他们需要什么样的装甲。我们对他们一无所知。林肯决定，联邦军队需要更多关于士兵的信息，以便最好地分配资源。因此，他下令进行了一项庞大的研究，对联邦军队进行身体、医疗和心理方面的评估。然后，严格遵循凯特莱的新科学，计算并报告了平均值。他们实际上说，基本上，我们正在跟随这个新领域的父亲的脚步，
Ketalai. These freshly calculated averages informed the distributions of food rations and the design of weapons. For example, if you were going to create muskets, well, how far is the trigger? And you could actually calculate average reach for soldier. This also affected military uniforms, which used to be all custom-sum. But in the Civil War, so many people had to be outfitted that custom uniforms would be impossibly expensive. So the uniforms had to be mass-produced. But they couldn't be just all one big floppy size.
凯特莱。这些新计算出的平均值指导了口粮的分配和武器的设计。例如，如果你要制造滑膛枪，那么扳机有多远？你实际上可以计算出士兵的平均臂展。这也影响了军服，过去军服都是全定制的。但在内战中，必须为如此多的人配备装备，定制军服将是极其昂贵的。所以军服必须大规模生产。但它们不能全都是一个臃肿的大号。
And so now they're realizing, oh, well, you know, if we break it into subtypes, like there's a large, and this is what we mean by it You know this big of a torso this brought a shoulders, you know small medium large That's gonna carry over into the way they think about the mass production of clothing. Yep. The size of small medium and large Which might be on your t-shirt tag those came out of this massive civil war study So you can thank Ketalai and Lincoln for that. This study in the civil war was the basis for the American military's long-standing philosophy of standardized average-based design. And that's going to become the fundamental design philosophy
所以现在他们意识到，哦，好吧，你知道，如果我们把它分成子类型，比如有一个大号，这就是我们的意思，你知道这么大的躯干，这么宽的肩膀，你知道小号、中号、大号。这将延续到他们对服装大规模生产的思考方式中。是的。小号、中号和大号的尺寸，可能会出现在你的T恤标签上，它们就来自这场庞大的内战研究。所以你可以为此感谢凯特莱和林肯。这场内战中的研究，成为了美国军队长期奉行的标准化基于平均值的设计哲学的基石。这将成为从内战开始的
from the civil war forward. So in 1926, when the army was designing its first ever fighter plane cockpit, engineers measured the physical dimensions of hundreds of male pilots and used this data to standardize cockpit dimensions. Of course, the possibility of female pilots was never considered. Of course. The size and shape of the seat, the distance to the pedals and the stick, the height of the windshield, even the shape of the flight helmets were all made to conform to the average 1920s male pilot, which changed the way the pilots were selected. You basically then select people that fit into that and then exclude people that don't.
基本设计哲学。所以在1926年，当军队设计其历史上第一款战斗机座舱时，工程师们测量了数百名男飞行员的身体尺寸，并利用这些数据来标准化座舱尺寸。当然，根本没有考虑过会有女飞行员的可能性。当然。座椅的大小和形状、到踏板和操纵杆的距离、风挡的高度，甚至飞行头盔的形状，全都是为了符合1920年代的平均男飞行员而制造的，这改变了飞行员的选拔方式。你基本上就是挑选适合这个尺寸的人，然后把不适合的人排除在外。
And this cockpit design worked okay, up to World War II. What happened was though, is that in World War II, it became an Air Force War, right? That was the first time when the Air Force would be the determinant of who was gonna win the war, and we absolutely ran out of pilots. The government recruited hundreds of new pilots, an expanded military aviation.
这种座舱设计效果还算可以，一直持续到二战。然而发生的情况是，在二战中，这变成了一场空军战争，对吧？那是空军第一次成为决定谁将赢得战争的关键，而我们的飞行员绝对不够用了。政府招募了数百名新飞行员，扩大了军用航空规模。
There's been a bunch of money on fancy new planes. Although the cockpits were still designed for the average 1920s male pilot. And this new big bad military force was going to fly the fastest and the highest and be the best. But that's not what happened. They actually had a pretty massive decline in performance, including just a rash of deaths. Pilots were dying all the time. Even after the war ended, just in training, they could not control their planes. It became kind of part of the culture of the Air Force where, hey, it's just really dangerous to fly. No one knew what was going on.
花了一大笔钱买那些花哨的新飞机。尽管座舱仍然是为1920年代的平均男飞行员设计的。而这支崭新且强大的强大军队将飞得最快、最高，成为最优秀的。但事实并非如此。他们的表现实际上出现了相当大规模的下滑，甚至发生了一连串的死亡事故。飞行员一直在死。甚至在战争结束后，仅仅是在训练中，他们也无法控制自己的飞机。这甚至成了空军文化的一部分，那就是：嘿，飞行实在太危险了。没有人知道发生了什么。
Some people thought, well, these ain't propeller planes anymore, maybe these new pilots just can't deal with the new aviation technology. And then they were like, well, maybe you got to train them better, and they did their better training programs, and that didn't work. After blaming the pilots, the training programs, and the technology, it finally dons on them,
有人认为，这些不再是螺旋桨飞机了，也许这些新飞行员只是无法应对新的航空技术。然后他们觉得，也许你们得更好地训练他们，于是他们实施了更好的训练程序，但那没有用。在指责了飞行员、训练程序和技术之后，他们终于恍然大悟，
what if it's the cockpit? Maybe it doesn't fit us anymore. Their first instinct is to think, we've just gotten bigger as a people. So the old average from 1922 is just too small, right? We're just bigger and better and like, let's build a better average. So in 1950, researchers at Wright Air Force Base in Ohio
会不会是座舱的问题？也许它不再适合我们了。他们的第一直觉是，我们作为人类体型变大了。所以1922年的旧平均值太小了，对吧？我们体型更大、更棒了，让我们建立一个更好的平均值吧。所以在1950年，俄亥俄州莱特空军基地的研究人员
were tasked with finding this new average. And one of those researchers was a man named Gilbert S. Daniels. Daniels was a Harvard graduate who had written his thesis on the average sizes of his class mate's hands. He was 23 years old, small, skinny, nerdy, not a military man at all. And he travels all over the country to different air force bases, and his job is to take these tape measures and just measure like 147 different dimensions of body size. It's got to be the most tedious job ever.
任务是寻找这个新的平均值。其中一位研究人员名叫吉尔伯特·S·丹尼尔斯。丹尼尔斯是哈佛大学的毕业生，他的毕业论文就是关于同学手部平均尺寸的研究。他当时23岁，身材矮小、瘦弱、书生气十足，一点也不像军人。他走遍了全国不同的空军基地，他的工作就是拿着这些卷尺，测量体型的147种不同维度。这绝对是有史以来最枯燥的工作。
And as Daniels is traveling around, from base to base, measuring thousands of airmen, he's realizing this incredible variability from person to person, even within this limited demographic of young men. As he was measuring hands and legs and wastes and foreheads, Daniels kept asking himself, how many pilots were actually average? So he reports back. So he goes to them and says, like, I think there's a problem with the average and he says, I just want to do this side study.
随着丹尼尔斯在各个基地之间奔波，测量了数千名飞行员，他意识到人与人之间存在着令人难以置信的差异，即使在这个年轻男子的有限人口统计群体内也是如此。在测量手、腿、腰和前额时，丹尼尔斯不断地问自己：到底有多少飞行员是真正处于平均水平的？于是他汇报了情况。他去找他们说，我觉得平均值有问题，他说，我只想做这个辅助研究。
I want to know if we take the 10 dimensions of size that matter most for design. Like say, shoulder width, height, chest, circumference, sleeve length, et cetera. How many of these pilots are actually average on all 10 of those dimensions? Daniels crunched the numbers. And of the 4,063 pilots he measured,
我想知道，如果我们选取对设计最重要的10个尺寸维度。比如肩宽、身高、胸围、袖长等。在这10个维度上，究竟有多少飞行员真正处于平均水平？丹尼尔斯计算了这些数字。在他测量的4063名飞行员中，
not a single airman was close to average in all of the 10 dimensions. None. Not one. And it got even worse, like if you just used three dimensions of size, less than 5% of the pilots were average on those. So he quickly realizes, like, wait, now you know the problem, if you are designing something for an average pilot, it's literally designed to fit nobody. And then this new era of jet-powered aviation were pilots were making split-second decisions
没有一个飞行员在所有10个维度上都接近平均水平。一个都没有。连一个也没有。情况甚至更糟，如果你只看三个尺寸维度，只有不到5%的飞行员在这些维度上是平均水平。所以他很快意识到，等等，现在你知道问题所在了，如果你为平均飞行员设计某样东西，它实际上是谁也穿不下。而在新一代喷气式动力航空时代，飞行员必须做出生死攸关的瞬间决定。
that could be life or death. It really mattered that pilots could reach what they needed to reach in a cockpit. The military is spraying into action pretty much right away. For the military to be willing to basically drop generations of design philosophy, right? Because it doesn't take them more than a few years to just be like, you can't design on average anymore. Air Force engineers and contractors designed adjustable foot pedals and adjustable helmet straps and flight suits and adjustable seats. You just can't believe that we were building planes with no adjustable seats. That's how much faith we had in the average person. Once all the adjustable
飞行员能否在座舱里够到他们需要的东西至关重要。军方几乎立刻采取了行动。军方愿意彻底抛弃几代人的设计哲学，这并不容易，对吧？因为他们只花了几年时间就意识到：你不能再按照平均值进行设计了。空军工程师和承包商设计了可调节的脚踏板、可调节的头盔带、飞行服和可调节座椅。你简直不敢相信我们以前制造的飞机竟然没有可调节座椅。这就是我们对平均人的盲目信任。一旦所有可调节
elements and other design solutions were put into place, pilot performance soared. And of course, now we take this for granted. That equipment should fit a wide range of body sizes instead of standardized around one average. You wouldn't buy a car that didn't have adjustable seats, right? That's just crazy. And it seeps into there pretty quickly in terms of automobiles and then you see what's interesting is the whole idea of ergonomics that all comes off of this period of time. We're where to jump starts the science of ergonomics which is not just for office chairs.
元件和其他设计解决方案到位后，飞行员的表现急剧飙升。当然，现在我们认为这是理所当然的。设备应该适应广泛的身体尺寸，而不是围绕一个平均值进行标准化。你不会买一台没有可调节座椅的汽车，对吧？那太疯狂了。这种理念很快渗透到了汽车领域，然后你会发现有趣的是，整个人体工学概念都源自这一时期。我们正是从这里开启了人体工学科学，而它不仅仅适用于办公椅。
Well it's really the study of work is what you could boil it down to but it really is a matter of matching people's capacities to the job. This is Professor Kyrissa Harris-Adamson, Director of the UCSF UC Berkeley Ergonomics Program. It's really important not to go with the average a lot of the time. If we want to incorporate, say, a handle into something, well we'll look up the Anthropometry data and make sure we identify the gripspan that we think is best. Or if we're designing a crank and we want it to be at a certain height, then we will go back to the Anthropometry data and figure out what makes the most sense to accommodate as much of the population as we can. Keeping in mind that in the US, most of the measurements we base our designs on still come from the US Army. That's primarily the source that we use in, say, ergonomic books or when we're designing for the workplace.
嗯，这实际上是对工作的研究，你可以把它归结为这一点，但它确实是将人类的能力与工作相匹配的问题。这是UCSF加州大学伯克利分校人体工学项目主任基里萨·哈里斯-亚当森教授。很多时候，不采用平均值真的非常重要。如果我们想在某个东西上加入手柄，我们会查阅人体测量数据，确保确定我们认为最佳的握距。如果我们正在设计一个曲柄，并希望它处于某个高度，那么我们会回到人体测量数据中，找出最合理的设计，以适应尽可能多的人口。请记住，在美国，我们设计依据的大多数测量数据仍然来自美国陆军。这主要是我们在人体工学书籍中或为工作场所设计时使用的来源。
And what we found is that those numbers are actually all pretty representative today, except for weight and abdominal growth. Which is part of why the world is so hard for heavier people to navigate. The military might be considered a more fit population than the rest of us. So does this mean that like military measurements affect the way our cars are designed? Absolutely. The measurements of our military personnel over the years affect just about everything. Military measurements are the most public and accessible.
而我们发现，除了体重和腹部增长外，这些数字在今天其实都相当具有代表性。这也是为什么较重的人在这个世界上出行如此困难的部分原因。与我们其他人相比，军队可能被认为是一个体能更好的人群。那么，这是否意味着军队的测量数据影响了我们汽车的设计？绝对是的。多年来，我们军事人员的测量数据几乎影响了一切。军事测量数据是最公开、最容易获取的。
And they work okay. They're not perfect, sure, but they're getting more inclusive. They've done a really good job in a calm day more of the population, given that women are now a very vibrant part of our military force. When the military opted to design for a greater range of people, they designed for a greater range of opportunity. Take for example, Kim Campbell. She was a fighter pilot and she flew a A10 Warhog and if it's worth googling,
而且它们效果还不错。它们当然不完美，但它们正变得更具包容性。鉴于女性现在是我们军事力量中充满活力的一部分，他们在让更多人适应方面做得非常好。当军队选择为更广泛的人群进行设计时，他们也为更广泛的机遇进行了设计。以金·坎贝尔为例。她是一名战斗机飞行员，驾驶过A-10“疣猪”攻击机，如果你觉得值得谷歌一下的话，
it is like the baddest looking plane you're ever gonna see. That's Todd Rose again, by the way, helping us tell the story of Captain Campbell. In 2003, Campbell was sent on a mission to assist some Marines who were trying to take a bridge in Iraq, they were under heavy fire, but on her way back her plane gets shot and she loses all control. She has the option to eject right there and save her life, but then the plane spirals into Baghdad and kills a bunch of innocent people. So she says like I'm not going to do that. She stabilizes,
它绝对是你见过的最酷的飞机。顺便说一下，那是托德·罗斯，在帮我们讲述坎贝尔上尉的故事。2003年，坎贝尔被派往伊拉克执行一项任务，支援试图夺取一座桥梁的海军陆战队，他们遭到猛烈炮火攻击，但在回程中她的飞机被击中，她失去了所有控制。她当时可以选择直接弹射跳伞保住性命，但那样的话飞机就会盘旋着坠入巴格达并杀死无辜平民。所以她说我不会那样做。她稳住了飞机，
which I don't even know how you do. And she flies back and then she says, look, I think I can land this plane. And she lands the massive, damaged, uncontrollable plane. It's an incredible heroic feat, really unprecedented. So of course, Kim Campbell gets awards and distinctions. And she is someone who could have never been one of the best pilots in the world, had the military not changed their design philosophy. She's the beneficiary of a cockpit that's flexibly designed because she's like five, four, and rail thin and doesn't look anything remotely close to an average sized pilot.
我甚至不知道你是怎么做到的。她飞了回来，然后她说，听着，我想我能把这架飞机降落。她成功降落了那架庞大、受损且无法控制的飞机。这是一个不可思议的英雄壮举，堪称史无前例。所以当然，金·坎贝尔获得了荣誉和勋章。如果军队没有改变他们的设计哲学，她本不可能成为世界上最优秀的飞行员之一。她是一个灵活设计的座舱的受益者，因为她身高五尺四寸（约1.6米），瘦骨嶙峋，看起来一点也不像平均身材的飞行员。
When Kim gets into a cockpit, she has to put the seat all the way up and pull the pedals all the way out, but it fits. This idea of equal fit as the foundation for how we think about real opportunity in society, I think has serious consequences for the future of design. In this concept that fit makes opportunity, it's an important one for Todd, because he believes that we can design environments and equipment and even entire systems to accommodate more and more people. When we think about how we design environments,
当金坐进座舱时，她必须把座椅调到最高，把踏板拉到最远，但它确实合适。这种将“平等适配”作为我们思考社会中真正机遇的基础的理念，我认为对设计的未来具有深远的影响。在“适配创造机遇”这个概念中，对托德来说非常重要，因为他相信我们可以设计出能够容纳越来越多的的环境、设备甚至整个系统。当我们思考如何设计环境时，
in a lot of fields, we've made some progress around accommodating wider ranges of people, but actually in things like education, we still actually design for this mythical average person under the assumption that if you design something that fit an average person, it would actually fit most people. By re-examining the concept of the average and acknowledging its limitations, we can maybe start to consider other ways of assessing and categorizing test scores or clothing sizes
在许多领域，我们在适应更广泛人群方面取得了一些进展，但实际上在教育等领域，我们仍然为这个神话般的普通人进行设计，其假设是：如果你设计出的东西适合普通人，它实际上就会适合大多数人。通过重新审视平均值的概念并承认其局限性，我们或许可以开始考虑评估和分类考试成绩、服装尺寸的其他方法
or wellness or happiness or worth. We can pave the way for more people who are outside of the average, because really, no one is average. 99% of visible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, which refutes of Katie Mangle, Emmett Fitzgerald, Kurt Colstead, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. If you want to know more, maybe you want to know how average came to mean subpar, instead of ideal, check out Todd Rose's book, it's called The End of Average, how we succeed in a world that values sameness. We had music, Marpal, okay, Akumi this week and lots of Lelotone, love Lelotone,
或健康、幸福或价值。我们可以为更多超越平均水平的人铺平道路，因为实际上，没有人是平均的。本周的“99%隐形”由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·曼格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、库尔特·科尔斯特德、萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马尔斯协助。如果你想了解更多，也许你想知道为什么“平均”会从“理想”变成“低于标准”，去看看托德·罗斯的书吧，书名叫《平均的终结：我们在崇尚整齐划一的世界中如何成功》。本周我们有音乐Marpal、Okay、Akumi以及大量的Lelotone，我爱Lelotone，
full track list and links to purchase at 99pi.org. We are a project of 91.7 KALW, San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, the corridor of Broadway, where all the radio is made. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We're taking off next week to take some deep breaths and recover from the extra work we've had to do with different people being away on vacation, so look for us in two weeks. I hope you're taking some time off too. If you find yourself in need of a story, I bet you can find one you didn't hear the first time on leadylinepi.org.
完整的曲目列表和购买链接请访问 99pi.org。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，制作于百老汇走廊的“广播排”（Radio Row）——所有广播诞生地，位于美丽加利福尼亚州奥克兰市的市中心。我们下周将休息，深呼吸一下，并从因不同人员度假而不得不承担的额外工作中恢复过来，所以请在两周后关注我们。希望你也抽出一些时间休息。如果你发现自己需要一个故事，我敢打赌你可以在leidylinepi.org上找到一个你以前没听过的故事。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可留。